Schon in drei jahren soll ein sehr ungewöhnliches gefährt auf dem mars zum einsatz
Kommen die nasa hat speziell für den. Roten planeten. Einen hubschrauber entwickelt. Und schon den. Drei. Jahren, solle auf dem mars starten. Dafür muss
Er allerdings vollkommen neu konstruiert werden denn auf der erde flugfähige helikopter würden auf den mars nicht einmal abheben mir
Das ganze trotzdem funktioniert. Und wo die risiken liegen dass jetzt den. Blick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Satelliten können sich der mars. Oberfläche
Nur auf eine entfernung von einigen kilometer nähern und das ist schon sehr. Nah trotzdem müssen sie schnell fliegen und brauchen sehr hochauflösende
Instrumente, um die oberfläche zu untersuchen deshalb plant die nasa jetzt, ein einmaliges experiment, denn. Ein
Experiment ist es denn. Noch nie wurde in der raumfahrt ähnliches versucht mit der mars mission mars
Two thousand and I wird es jetzt einmalig. Einen helikopter auf dem mars. Geben. Dabei sind die technischen voraussetzungen
Erheblich denn, hier auf der erde liegt der höhenrekord für hubschrauber bei rund 13 kilometern da die luft auf dem mars aber
So dünn ist gleich in die bedingungen auf der mars. Oberfläche also ganz unten schon den. Hier auf der erde in einer
höhe von rund 30 kilometern
Der hubschrauber muss also gänzlich anders. Konstruiert werden. So drehen sich die rotorblätter mit 3000 umdrehungen in der minute. Zehn mal schneller als
auf der erde und das gewicht des fluggerätes darf nicht, hoch seien, 1,8 kilo wiegt die köpfe unter den rotorblättern und
Muss dabei einiges an technologie transportieren die kapsel ist in etwa
So groß, wie ein fußball und muss zusätzlich zum motor weiteren technik enthalten
Um einsatzbereit so bleiben so muss die technik zb in den mars nächten beheizt werden
Weil die kälte ansonsten sie beschädigen würde zudem braucht der helikopter
Elektronik für einen autopiloten da die entfernung zum mars, zu groß ist um das fluggerät in echtzeit
zu steuern, ein signal würde mehrere licht minuten benötigen
Um dort anzukommen das projekt wird von der nasa als ein hochrisiko projekt gesehen, zu viele unwägbarkeiten
könnten dieses
experimentelle fluggerät zum scheitern bringen allerdings
Wäre es der hammer wenn es klappen würde einfach
Mal über den nächsten hügel gucken was da ist das war bisher
Noch nicht möglich aber wenn's klappt dann werden die jetzt hier natürlich zuerst erfahren wenn. Ihr zu den ersten gehören wollte, ihn?
Dabei, sind dann endet. Meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp wenn. Ihr wollt könnt. Ihr?
Euch auch mit kilogramm instagram oder dem facebook manager mit wir verknüpfen dann erfahrt. Ihr von mir vor allen
Anderen, vom neuesten videothek nicht garantiert. Ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von finck somit machen
Und zum beispiel themen vorschlagen einfach hier drauflegen. Und zur begrüßung habe ich. Ein kleines goodie
Und natürlich nicht das abo mit der. Genau der glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
sensationsfund auf dem mars ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran